Il y a encore une chose à propos des plus grosses mangues du monde.
Le collège du monde est parce que dans un seul arbre
Vous repartez avec toutes les mangues du monde.
Non, nous n'avons pas besoin de mangues du monde entier.
peut être lu facilement
Depuis l'enfance, nous allions et venions à la crèche avec notre père.
Garderie
nous nous sommes étalés
Il était mineur lorsque nous l'avons rencontré à l'âge de 17 ans.
de la
[musique]
Le gouvernement devrait accorder toute son attention
Je crains que si la situation continue ainsi, les gens devraient postuler.
Va partir et les gens s'en éloignent
Parce que nous voulons d'abord ça
Nos enfants sont dans la lignée de l'agriculture
Je suis venu au meurtre, maintenant ces enfants en souffrent.
C'est pourquoi nous n'y voyons aucun avenir.
de personnes
[musique]